[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en première position madame christiane
taubira avec une mention bien plus je
rappelle que les participants étaient
invités à des mentions à chacun d'eux
très bien insuffisant ce qu'on appelle
le vote au meilleur jugement
[Applaudissements]
cette primaire était en réalité dès le
départ taillé pour permettre à
christiane taubira d'être candidate bon
donc tout ça est quand même relativement
peu plus flamboyant vous pouvez pas dire
avec simplicité qu'une primaire a été
taillée sur mesure pour moi d'abord
j'aurais perdu
j'aurais fait 90 9% si ça avait été le
cas mais surtout c'est extrêmement
irrespectueux vis-à-vis des personnes
qui ont organisé ces primaires en
troisième position monsieur jean luc
mélenchon avec une mention assez bien
moi je suis pas concerné j'ai été
inscrits d'office dans une élection à
laquelle je ne voulais pas participer
voilà on a une candidature de plus on va
diviser les scores les électeurs et les
ex crise de gauche vont sans doute être
très en colère et peut-être une partie
s'abstiendront à l'hidalgo humilié par
une majorité d'insuffisant et de
passable ce qui eu mention passable plus
autant dire redoublement avec un au bar
ans aurait pu être un moment de
rassemblement et de rang rassemblement
de toute la gauche pour une candidature
unique c'est une candidature de plus je
ne me rallierai pas derrière christiane
taubira est là pour l'instant pas de
programme a été désigné et donc on ne
sait même pas sur quel programme elle va
se présenter cette réaction cette
hauteur cette distance pardon mais
mépris et peut-être un mot trop fort
mais cette façon de tenir quand même en
distance de façon hautaine un processus
démocratique je suis sûr d'être sourire
bon face à qui d'ailleurs je parle c'est
manuel là et c'est logique d'ailleurs
parce que je pense qu'il ya là les deux
visions de la france qui s'affrontent
pour les 20 ans à venir les procédés à
cette déloyaux parfois utilisé par un
certain nombre de gens m'ont poussé à
anticiper
la décision
et j'ai annoncé que je soutiendrai le
pen marine le pen et marion maréchal ne
sont pas seulement une tente et une
nièce mais ça c'est leur problème privé
en revanche ce sont des femmes
politiques elle incarne des lignes dont
on sait qu'elles sont différentes depuis
des années elle conseille de vous
donneriez à marion maréchal pour les
jours et les semaines et les mois et les
années à venir un conseil ne penser à
son mariage et à la naissance de son
enfant
je ne lui conseillerais puisque est
écarté de la politique est bien
d'attendre un peu dire venir
efficacement depuis la diffusion du
reportage de zone interdite sur l'islam
radical à roubaix la présentatrice
ophélie meunier a été placé sous
protection policière face aux menaces
reçues j'ai fait le métier que j'estime
devoir faire sur une émission dont in
fine et la décision mais revenu je la
revendique d'avoir autorisé cette
émission à roubaix à 2 heures 3 heures
de paris c'est l'afghanistan c'est ça le
vrai sujet a filmé du début à la fin par
ce milliardaire tchèque radim passèrent
trente troisième fortune mondiale
suite aux propositions de la dgsi et
donc au moment où nous parlons
l'intégralité des versions du pr été
menacés sont protégés par la police
nationale nous retrouverons les auteurs
il accélère progressivement
200-300 pousse encore
jusqu'à 4 114 km
[Musique]